حيث قالت الاداره العسكريه ان العاصمه
تعرضت لهجوم روسي بالصواريخ والطائرات
المسيره وقد وصفت الهجوم الذي يعتبر
التاسعه على التوالي منذ بدايه الشهر مايو
ايار الجاري بانه غير مسبوق في كثافته
وقوته وتنوعه واكدت الاداره ان الهجوم تم
بصواريخ كروز اطلقت من بحر قزوين واستخدمت
فيه طائرات مسيره ايضا واكدت ان الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه اسقطت جميع الاهداف الروسيه
المهاجمه في سماء كييف ودمرتها
معنى من مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود ومنف
مراسل جزيره تامر الصمادي ابدا معك حسان
اذا ما هي اخر التطورات في كييف بعد هذا
الهجوم
اخر التطورات هو ما اعلن عنه
المتحدث باسم قياده القوات الجويه كما
ايضا اكده القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه من ان الهجوم الصاروخي المكثف
الذي شهدته اوكرانيا خلال هذه الليله وفجر
هذا اليوم جاء ب 30 صاروخا بشكل متزامن من
اماكن مختلفه برا وبحرا وجوا تحدث عن
اطلاق 22 صاروخا من طراز كروز من طائرات
قاذفات استراتيجيه من طراز ستوبوليف 95
160 من فوق بحر قزوين بالاضافه الى اطلاق
سته صواريخ من طراز كروز
وكاليبر تحديدا اطلقت من البحر الاسود
وكذلك صاروخان من طراز اسكندر كذلك اطلقت
باتجاه الاراضي الاوكرانيه هذه الهجمه
المتزامنه تعتبر من بين الهجمات المكثفه
والمعقده التي اطلقت نحو الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وفق المعطيات الرسميه التي
جاءت ايضا بالتوازي مع اطلاق عدد من
المسيرات
بشكل ايضا متزامن في محاوله للتشويش على
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه تحدثت ايضا
قياده القوات الجويه عن اسقاط مسيرتين من
طراش شاهد وهي مسيرات انتحاريه وكذلك
مسيرتين استطلاعتين ايضا هذه المسيرات
اطلقت بشكل متزامن مع الصواريخ نحن الان
في موقع اخر من المواقع التي تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه انها اسقطت فوقها صواريخ في
سماء العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف حتى هذه
اللحظه هناك حديث عن ثلاث احياء مختلفه في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف سقطت فيها
الصواريخ قبل قليل كنا في احد الاحياء
والان نحن في حي اخر احدث الصاروخ الذي
سقط هنا رغم انه وفق الروايه الرسميه لم
ينفجر حفره بقطر عشره امتار هنا في هذا
الحي في حي دارنيسكي بالعاصمه الاوكرانيه
وتعمل فرق الانقاذ على على ازاله اثار هذا
الصاروخ ربما لو سقط هذا الصاروخ في مكان
يبعد امطار قليله كما تشاهدون في الخلفيه
للمبنى لاصاب واحدث ضررا كبيرا في هذه
المنطقه لكنه سقط في منطقه
محايده كما شاهدنا وهذه الهجمه تقول
السلطات الاوكرانيه انها تصدت خلالها ل 29
صاروخا من اصل
32 صاروخ التي اطلقت باتجاه العاصمه
الاوكرانيه وعدد من المناطق الاوكرانيه
هذا القصف ياتي في اطار
واضح بوتيره الهجمات الصاروخيه نحو
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف تحديدا وعدد طبعا
من المناطق الاوكرانيه ونتحدث عن ضربات
صاروخيه بمعدل ضربه صاروخيه كل يومين منذ
بدايه شهر مايو الاداره العسكريه في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف تحدثت عن ان هذه
الهجمه اليوم هي الهجمه التاسعه على
التوالي
والتي تعتبر من الهجمات غير المسبوقه
والمتواصله على العاصمه الاوكرانيه منذ
بدايه شهر مايو كنا نلاحظ ان الهجمات على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه تحدث مره او مرتين كل
شهر لكننا الان بدانا نرصد هذا الارتفاع
بالوتيره وكما قالت المتحدث باسم قياده
عمليات الجنوب ان هذا التصاعد في الهجمات
بهذا الشكل
المتزامن وبهذا الشكل الكثيف هو في محاوله
لاستنزاف الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه التي
تحاول ان تتصدر
للهجمات التي تقوم بها القوات الروسيه
بصواريخ من انواع مختلفه ومن مناطق مختلفه
وبشكل متزامن